♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
The Biden administration
last week
called for new regulations
on regional banks.
I'm kidding. We're only
doing fun stuff today.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Regional banks.
Get outta here!
[ Laughter and applause ]
A Manhattan grand jury voted
on Thursday
to indict former President Trump
for allegedly making
a hush money payment
to adult film star
Stormy Daniels.
But if you think this is the end
for Donald Trump,
I have a bus to sell you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After it was reported
on Thursday
that a Manhattan grand jury
had voted to indict him,
former President Trump
had dinner at Mar-a-Lago
with former
First Lady Melania Trump.
It was a poignant moment
in their relationship
and Trump and Melania
very tenderly and lovingly
split the check.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Trump ]
So, your half is $38.50.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
is set tomorrow
to be fingerprinted
and photographed
and then the next step
will be to sit back
and see how many cold cases
that solves.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"We, uh --
[ Cheering ]
Chief, you're not going
to believe this.
We got news on the
Westchester Strangler."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's lawyers
are reportedly
considering asking
to have his trial moved
from Manhattan to Staten Island.
Ah, yes, the Mar-a-Lago
of New York.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What are they going
to sentence him to,
a parade?
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Trump's lawyers want
to have Trump's trial moved
from Manhattan to Staten Island.
Normally, if you want
to move something
from Manhattan to Staten Island,
you just throw it
in a trash can.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Baze.
Alex -- make your letters
out to Alex Baze.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department and FBI
reportedly have evidence
that former President Trump
possibly obstructed
the investigation
into classified documents found
at his Mar-a-Lago home.
Trump is reportedly
still digesting the news
and the documents.
[ Laughter ]
A couple in Michigan recently
pulled into a Costco parking lot
to give birth to their baby
while on their way
to the hospital.
They also picked up
some snacks and toiletries
because how often do you find
a parking space at Costco?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Just breathe, honey,
I'm going to run in."
[ Laughter ]
Today was zoologist
Jane Goodall's 89th birthday.
Her friends threw a party
and their feces.
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
McDonald's --
[ Laughter ]
McDonald's has reportedly
closed down
its corporate offices
temporarily
to prepare for layoffs,
so, if you were looking
to burglarize them,
now might be a good time.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today was Don't Go
to Work Unless It's Fun Day.
But don't worry, it is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
yesterday signed a bill
that allows residents to carry
concealed loaded weapons
without a permit,
UConn won the NCAA tournament,
and Finland joined NATO,
and I think that's
all the other stuff.
Now...
[ Laughter ]
...former President Trump
was arraigned today inside the
New York County Criminal Court
in lower Manhattan
and I think it really
says something
that the craziest part
of that sentence is still
"former President."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That guy
was the president
of the country.
If you asked for the manager
at Best Buy
and that guy came over,
you'd say, "No.
The man-a-ger."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right,
former President Trump
was arraigned today
in Manhattan.
And like anyone else,
Trump is presumed innocent
until he outright confesses
on Truth Social.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trump was arraigned today
inside a New York courtroom.
Cameras weren't allowed,
but they did have
a sketch artist.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump was set
to speak tonight at Mar-a-Lago
following his arraignment today
in New York.
Wait, they're letting him go?
[ Laughter ]
Does anything scream
"flight risk" more
than a guy with his own plane?
[ Laughter ]
It's a flight guarantee.
Attorney Todd Blanche announced
yesterday that he's joined
former President Trump's
criminal defense team
and said joining the team was,
"an opportunity
he could not pass up."
An opportunity to what,
also go to prison?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I mean,
who wouldn't want to join
the illustrious ranks
of Michael Cohen and the guy
who didn't know Four Seasons
was a hotel?
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
warned yesterday
that the city is prepared
for former President Trump's
arraignment and said,
"While there may be
some rabble-rousers thinking
about coming
to our city tomorrow,
our message is clear
and simple --
control yourselves."
My question is
where was that leadership
before SantaCon?
[ Laughter ]
Kellen Curry,
an Afghanistan war veteran
and former executive
at JPMorgan,
announced this week
that he will challenge
New York Congressman
George Santos
in the Republican primary.
Sounds impressive.
Do we have a photo of Curry?
George!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Disney CEO Bob Iger criticized
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
yesterday
for his decision
to strip the company
of its special
self-governing status
and, to get him back,
announced Minnie
is just Mickey in drag.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Paris residents
over the weekend voted
to ban electric scooters
from the city, which is wise,
because it's really hard
to fall in love with someone
once you've seen them ride
a scooter.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
today was Tell a Lie Day.
Said one celebrant --
[ As Trump ]
Not guilty.
Former President Trump pleaded
not guilty yesterday
to 34 charges of falsifying
business records.
Well, his voice pleaded
not guilty.
His face pleaded guilty as hell.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Former President Trump
spoke last night at Mar-a-Lago
following his arraignment
and said,
"I never thought anything like
this could happen in America."
Honestly, neither did I.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you got away
with so many crimes,
for so long.
Trump getting arrested
was like "Avatar" 2.
I just figured it was
never going to happen.
[ Laughter ]
Then it finally did
and I was like, "You know what?
Worth the wait."
[ Laughter and applause ]
In his speech
at Mar-a-Lago last night,
after his arraignment,
former President Trump
thanked his family and said,
"I have a great family
and they've done a fantastic job
and we appreciate it very much."
Great that he likes his family,
[ Laughter ]
but why does he talk about them
the way a high school principal
talks about the prom committee?
[ Laughter ]
"They've done a great job.
We really appreciate them
and, uh, hey, it looks like
we're Under the Sea.
[ Laughter ]
Give them a hand."
Eric Trump retweeted a photo
of former President Trump
in court yesterday
with the caption...
No, dude, it's your father.
[ Laughter ]
What --
What is wrong with this family?
[ Laughter ]
After former President Trump's
post-arraignment event
at Mar-a-Lago last night,
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene said
that Trump was "committed like
she's never seen him before."
Well, yeah, but that's
a pretty low benchmark.
[ Laughter ]
If he was committed before,
he wouldn't be in this mess
to begin with.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Fox News Chairman Rupert Murdoch
has reportedly called off
his engagement.
And just as his leg was healing
from getting down on one knee.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, 92-year-old
Fox News Chairman Rupert Murdoch
has reportedly called off
his engagement.
Yeah, don't rush into anything.
[ Laughter ]
You've got your whole
month ahead of you.
[ Laughter ]
Lawmakers in Texas
are considering two new bills
that would allow firearm safety
to be taught in high school
and, if there's money left over,
math.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's
attorney Joe Tacopina said,
in a new interview,
that it was a "relief"
to see the final charges
against Trump.
Alright, you know it's bad
when 34 felonies is a relief.
[ Laughter ]
Phew, really dodged
a bullet there.
[ Laughter ]
After attending a rally
in Manhattan
in support of former
President Trump on Tuesday,
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
criticized New York
during an interview
with Fox News host
Tucker Carlson and said,
"I think it's a very
terrible place."
But the joke's on you,
Marjorie,
because, once you think that,
you're officially a New Yorker.
[ Laughter ]
After he was arraigned
on Tuesday in Manhattan,
Former President Trump
reportedly sat
on the patio of Mar-a-Lago
and used his iPad to play music
over the club's speakers,
including "Macho Man"
by the Village People.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, man, you can't play that
here anymore,"
said the governor of Florida.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According to a new report
from the EPA,
there are more
than 1 million lead pipes
still in use in Florida.
And there are actually more
than that
in New Jersey, but they --
[ Italian accent ]
Don't wanna have to use them.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
You know what I mean?
Lamborghini this week unveiled
its first plug-in
hybrid supercar.
Now, you can help save
the planet for your children
from all three
of your marriages.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A government official
in Singapore
was recently sentenced
to two years in jail
after he allegedly sold more
than 600 stolen printer
cartridges online.
No word on what happened
to the trillions of dollars
he made.
[ Laughter ]
[ New York accent ]
I'm from the generation
where we had to buy
our own printer cartridges.
They get you on the cyan?
Is that the one
they get you on, Baze?
Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According to a new survey,
an estimated
44 million American adults
are experiencing
significant loneliness,
which explains why they were
willing to take a survey.
[ Laughter ]
"No, it's not --
it's not a bad time at all!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
A person walking
on a beach in Florida
recently found a 30-pound bale
of marijuana
and they admittedly
did the right thing
and reported the 25-pound bale
of marijuana.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
According to a new study,
poor sleep can increase
the risk of a stroke.
But on the plus side,
you got to hear this joke.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Two former prison guards
in Oklahoma
were recently sentenced
to probation
for allegedly forcing inmates
to listen to the song
"Baby Shark" as punishment.
[ Laughter ]
And it's worse than you think
because they played it twice.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, two former
prison guards in Oklahoma
were recently sentenced
to probation
for allegedly forcing inmates
to listen to the song
"Baby Shark."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
a local charity in New York
remains unpunished.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]